yo yo yo what's up it's Baron Davis aka
the presenter of Bart oatmeal the legend
get a bowl and you can catch me on the
bootleg Kev podcast show Believe
cat podcast we got a special guest in
here a legend
his name is Baron Davis aka bar oatmeal
yeah yeah I believe get a bow
um well first of all I just want to give
you props because uh I'm a basketball
fanatic and you were one of my favorite
players to ever watch I remember when
you got drafted by the Hornets like
watching like yeah them early Hornets
days man you was like a [__] you were
just like a shot of energy in the league
like
your size could dunk on everybody like
man you had you have to you know you
have to come in the league back then
like you have to make a name for
yourself you know what I mean you coming
in a league with you know you got
Juggernaut steel you got stocktons and
Malone's yeah they are like because when
you get drafted 99.99 yeah yeah so
that's like yeah Penny was still around
uh everybody just every kid was just
coming into his own Steve Nash just was
coming into his own so it was like the
the it was kind of before the wild point
guard Renaissance yeah yeah like
mid-2000 like 2010 I would say we had a
hell of a point guard Renaissance so my
air is pretty you know well I mean yeah
I mean especially I think that was the
start because you were coming in while a
lot of those guys like stocked yeah and
a traditional point guards Mark Jackson
we're going out yeah Mark Jackson was a
poster point guard Ross Strickland was a
get to the whole type of point guard so
they was okay I was there yeah I was in
his prime now I still don't know because
I hear people consider him okay he's
more of a shooting he was a shooting
guard on that team yeah Eric snow was
the point guard yeah he was a scoring
guard I remember those battles man you
playing against that dude he was sick
yeah
um yo I wanted to talk to you because I
feel like correct me if I'm wrong I
remember seeing something when I was
like younger when you were uh in the
league were you throwing up your
neighborhood like ever on video like
when you were like making shots and [__]
because that never happened no okay
because I wanted to ask you about how
you feel about the driving rant [__]
because obviously the driving range is
kind of interesting and you were
obviously a young kid who came from a
serious area of La yeah got drafted into
the league I'm sure you dealt with a lot
of [__] I was just Guilty By Association
but I I mean I don't
I don't remember you know maybe off the
court
but I don't remember like on the court
maybe I did you know sometimes you get
hyped you know what I'm saying like
anything happened but obviously you you
know you did a lot back then you feel
what I'm saying it was a lot we did a
lot back then and it was a lot of you
know if we had social media back then
everybody would be like have horrible
tarnished images you know what I mean
because it was just you know back in the
day like you could win no camera phones
so like whatever was cracking you know
right then and there it was what was
cracking like you have to have a video
person you have to tell somebody bring a
camera yeah you know what I mean back
then so you know a lot of people was
like not so much getting in trouble like
because I don't think John Moret is in
trouble you know what I mean like he did
some you know some stupid [__] right but
at the same time like we've been doing
like we've been doing stupid [__] for
the longest time a long time you know
this wasn't everyone now it's under a
microscope yeah yeah it's under a
microscope because you know I I was
saying to uh just to my friends man I'm
you know I cried on my 25th birthday I
cried on my 30th birthday and on my 35th
birthday I was like damn dude I'm gonna
make it I'm gonna actually live you know
what I mean and so just thinking about
you know that Journey from the time I
got drafted to the time I hit 30 was
just it was just a lot
coming back home you know what I mean
having to deal with that you know being
on the road people you know just during
the season people think you saw say
something to you you know you gotta go
find them in off season and see if it's
real oh wow you know what I mean like
just wow you know what I mean and like I
think once I kind of got to go to state
you know things just start kind of like
leveling out I was like man let me
change let me change who I am and and
like I don't need to be this this is not
me you know what I mean I'm not I'm not
like I'm not like this you know I want
to be what do you have to prove like I
didn't have [__] you're a [__] you
know you're a millionaire you're on TV
every day yeah and at the same time like
bro I'm scared to die yeah
it's real out here you know what I mean
like they would they shoot at athlete
out here back in the day crazy right
remember Jalen Rose got shot at mm-hmm
why are you shooting at Jalen Rose right
who the [__]
shoots at Jalen Rose you know what I
mean and he was on Sunset so I just you
know for me it was just like that era
was a lot of jacking you know it was a
lot of uh pressure extortion you know
the NBA players are getting extorted all
day NBA players rappers uh
musician anybody came to La it was just
not a good place to be you know what I
mean like if you got found or you was
out shopping it like if if you can stay
low cool but back then if you was you
was on the move and you get caught it I
mean you at that Mercy I was gonna say
because I I would like like obviously a
lot of the stuff is highly back to the
camera phones thing we see a lot more of
the people getting robbed on Sunset or
on Melrose and it's like yeah that kind
of [__] has always been happening in LA
but I feel like back in the day it was
really like Peak you kind of had to come
to LA and like
if you were going to move around you
really had to be in line with some guys
to make sure that there wasn't any sort
of yeah yeah that was the whole like uh
the tap in error the tap in error
people's chains were getting took people
had to get the chains yeah you get the
chain back we got it I mean
you know I got a couple chains back from
some for some uh some rappers actually
no basketball players whose chain did
you get
[Laughter]
I just know they one of my favorite you
know one of my favorites uh you know a
couple rappers man just
that's just how I be you know what I
mean like a couple rappers just like
come to LA tickets lost in and you got
to think like coming up in that game
there to air with the game when game was
first starting to like break out like it
was no blood rappers
it was no Bloods famous period you know
what I mean yeah if you really think
outside of mach 10 yeah it was Mac 10
and then and then the game and then
everybody was a blood everybody started
being Bloods you know what I mean so
imagine like
rocking with the blood that is on his on
his way up you know what I mean in L.A
so it was a lot to deal with with that
and he was the face of La for like a
decade yeah he had carried the whole
coach for like a very long time yeah and
and I think it just kind of for me like
hanging with game
made me realize that okay man my plan
was me and gang rocking together I mean
he can unify the music I can unify the
hoop and then we can create this
La unified system where like we can make
it better for dudes you know what I mean
like we can stop
all the jacking and [__] like that you
know what I'm saying like at least if
they [__] with us they rolling with
us
you ain't gonna get Robbie ain't gonna
get into no funny business you know what
I mean and like that was the goal is
really like once I saw that I was like
man like nip coming Don I'm coming you
know YG had had a couple songs but YG
was on his way you know what I mean it
was a bunch of dudes just like on they
rise and I was like damn dude uh Kenji
you know what I mean Jay Rock was out
but Jay Rock was like on his way so like
uh I remember we did the gang the
Crimson Bloods gang documentary and uh I
was like man I need to put a soundtrack
together
and on the soundtrack is all them dudes
like damn their first soundtrack right I
remember how long ago was that
documentary uh I think I want to say 20
2015 not 1204 I think 2004 yeah Jesus
Christ yeah it was like 2004 or when I
got to
it was like 2004. I think I was in New
Orleans when I came when you end up on
the Clippers
being a guy who's from where you're from
playing in La obviously not for the
Lakers but play for the Clippers for
sure you guys had a very very
entertaining team
um but was it like how much of the like
extra [__] did you have to deal with
being home
all of it uh you know what like playing
for the Clippers like and I never really
talk about that [__] because people
always talk about Dunleavy or Donald
Sterling right you know what I mean but
just playing for the Clippers like my
mission when I left golden state was
like all right I know the Clippers are
the Clippers right
coming back home to hopefully do what I
did in Golden State I told Golden State
give me three years you know what I mean
would be in the playoffs if we get the
right people around you know what I mean
like that's what I like that's what I
wanted to do so coming here it was like
yeah if I can get the Clippers to the
playoffs if I can turn the Clippers
around then it'll be a whole different
story you know what I mean so historical
at that point it would have been
historical
um and so like that was kind of like my
mission it was like I need to get
through those first three years
because the first three years is all
[__] you know what I mean you gotta
clean up you know all it just negative
[__] that be going around and you got to
protect your teammates and then you got
to build your teammates to where they
feel like they can walk in like we
walking in the season and like it's just
us you know what I mean and then it's us
and the coaches and then everybody else
it's our family you know what I mean and
I think with the Clippers it was just
that [__] was just hard bro actually it
was just hard because it was a lot of
racism sexism uh backstabbing people
telling lies snitching and [__] I was
like man I thought we kind of worked to
play basketball so all of the Donald
Sterling [__] was very accurate
extremely uh extremely accurate you know
um
I mean besides him you know being like a
piece of [__] in the scum of the earth
like he's actually that speaking of
extorted he got shook down for real
short he had him on the camera on video
yeah she did him dirty but but he
deserved it hell yeah he deserves he
deserved way more than that bro you know
what I mean you deserve a lot worse than
that uh
um it's crazy because I I went from
having this of like like a genuine like
love for the Warriors growing up as a
kid they were kind of like that fun team
to always watch and then obviously the
error of you Michael Petrus uh Barnes uh
J Rich was such a dope error but then
fast forward to this whole last like
decade of basketball
I [__] cannot stand these Warrior
fans now again because they knew they're
new yeah listen I lived in Tampa Florida
I was doing radio in Tampa at the time
when the Steph Curry and and the LeBron
and [__] was happening and I'm in Tampa
and all of a sudden there's just this
influx of Hardcore Warriors fans in the
middle of Florida amazing and I'm like
[Laughter]
where were y'all when Mitch Richmond was
there Chris Mullins
it's crazy because you have such like a
place in Bay Area history in Warrior
history what is it like for you to kind
of you like the Warriors are kind of
like a forgotten franchise and I feel
like you helped kind of re-establish
them on the map
but now they're like the franchise yep
what's that like to kind of just witness
like it's amazing man uh you know I just
consider myself the curse breaker you
are the curse breaker I am definitely
the curse breaker uh and I you know I
just kind of like I love watching the
Warriors play right obviously they play
the right way I'm a huge Steph Curry fan
yeah I never forget sand to the Warriors
like when I sign with the Clippers like
yeah I don't even like y'all gonna
forget about me like this kid is he's
next he's your future
um and when they win the championship I
feel like I win too you know what I mean
uh and you know I was I would say just
for us with the We Believe Squad and me
in the Bay Area it wasn't just the Honor
Court it was off the court it's being
accessible to the people at Oakland San
Francisco in the hood right and
corporate in Tech and so like you know
the Bay Area to me is home and that's
hard to say for La dude you know what I
mean but it's like I got I got real
family real real people who take care of
me you know what I mean uh in the Bay
Area and so like whether I'm in LA or
the base you know it there's no
difference and there's definitely no
hate you know what I'm saying in between
anymore so you know my goal was just
when I went to Golden State was like yo
like we got to establish ourselves as
somebody you know what I mean like we
can't just be like the dead corpse you
know what I mean or the Pacific Division
we got to have at least a style so if we
get beat like [__] is like oh
good game you know what I mean like I
got games you guys made this work yeah
but when I when I got there that [__]
was dead it was a you know it was just
like a lot of dead energy and dudes
didn't even want to play basketball so
for me it was like how the [__] don't
you want to play basketball this is like
how you relieve your stress your mental
health all that [__] like basketball was
that and so once we kind of like got to
a point I think the city was just like
hold on like we got people who actually
care yeah because nobody like before
whether you wanted to be there or not
you didn't know because they just kept
trading coaches and players in and out
yeah coach for you guys right Don Nelson
Mike Montgomery was the coach when I
first got there and then we had a little
success at the end of the year and then
they brought him back uh which was a bad
move for the second year
um and he started coaching you know what
I mean which is yeah
not probably something he didn't really
do well uh well he's a good dude
um
and then Don Nelson came in after Mike
Montgomery for the fire We Believe here
yeah crazy and then we believe here Doug
it was crazy uh you know we sucked that
year the whole year I mean you guys were
the eight seats you got snuck into the
playoffs barely snow right Mike uh at
All-Star break there was like we were
the odd person out kind of like the
Lakers this year yeah a lot like how the
Lakers were they were the 13th seed at
the All-Star game that's exactly where
we were and then all of a sudden we just
you hit a run like we figured it out you
know what I mean like were you there the
year that Steph got drafted or was that
in the off season
off season yeah so uh we missed the
playoffs
I go to the Clippers
the Clippers have a bad year the
Warriors have a bad year the Warriors
draft Steph Curry
you know Tim pick I think I'm a huge
Sons fan and I have to ask you because
you and this guy aren't necessarily tied
together but you guys do have some
kind of uh coincidental yeah we gotta
it's like yeah you and Chris Paul for
sure because obviously you leave the
Clippers yeah for sure you leave the
Hornets Chris Paul comes in with a
better team
um what's your relationship like with CP
and is there I mean listen I have
friends on the Suns and I would say most
of my friends are not too fond of Chris
what is your like does he get a bad rap
amongst other NBA players and how's your
guys's relationship because you guys are
kind of tied together with two
franchises yeah yeah and crazy enough uh
I got all the love and respect for Chris
Paul
when Chris Paul is at Wake Forest I
called Chris Paul when I was in the
league like yo bro I [__] with you I
think his grandfather died
and I was like man shouting you out like
you gonna you know what I mean just like
kind of like you know we have
Brotherhood at the end of the day for
sure so like me and Chris have always
been linked like that and so when I left
Charlotte New Orleans and he came in I I
kind of figured like all right I'm gonna
clean this [__] up and then I'm gonna
let Chris Paul me and Chris Paul gonna
come in and take it you know to another
level but you know I just think as a
player like he's an incredible point
guard yeah you know what I mean I think
that he's a legend yeah he's he's a
rising guy it feels like with like his
teammates yeah he's a big personality I
think when you look at him you think you
know CEO president you know what I mean
corporate you did President NBA Players
Association of the NBA players so when
you looking at that you know at your
leader out there on the floor you know
like he he coming with a full corporate
you know what I mean corporate like he's
running it he running that team the way
he want to run a team you feel very much
a coach on the floor Bingo yeah he'll be
a great he'll be a man excellent codes
for sure he would be an excellent coach
yeah he's like uh like you said like
he's he's very much he's running the
team away yeah he's just he worked yeah
he come in like his [__] is corporate
business you've played for a lot of
coaches and I do feel like that we'll
see certain teams like make a coaching
change and it's like day and night right
how important is
coach like a coach like on an NBA team
because a lot of times you'll hear I
guess
generic basketball fans it's about it's
in the player's hands like the players
ain't performing man no it's it's like
you played for some bad coaches you
played for some great coaches play with
some terrible coaches I played for some
great coaches too I played for some
coaches at
had we had one or two other pieces they
would have been Hall of Fame you know
what I mean championship coaches
um
the team Dynamic and the coach Dynamic
like you need a good coach good coaches
are hard to come by what determines a
good coach you know what I mean a lot of
coaches when they come into the business
they like they have established who they
are their style what they're gonna do
a lot of times
coaches that are players must separate
themselves from the players today in
order to be okay coaching them I was
gonna say you know what I mean it seems
like at times like if there's a guy who
used to play they kind of yeah hey dude
Mike Dunleavy he played in the league
and all he would talk about
in reference is when he played which was
like in the [__] 70s gives a [__]
right
you're not like and you're a point guard
so like I used to always be like like
yeah when I play I said coach
if you played in this area bro I swear
to God I elbow you in your face I follow
you to the locker room elbow you again
well he wasn't a great coach he was not
that great of a coach Mike doesn't leave
me but he was tough he wanted to get
along he he was his son ever on your
guys's team no I played with Mike Mike
Jr Mike Jr is dope he was cool I played
with Mike Jr in Golden State
um he actually got he was the trade he
was the person that they traded to
Indiana for stack uh and Al Harrington
but like such a crazy team it was it was
a how much weed was getting passed
around in that in those off off season
when you guys were like you know how
many moves together
everybody was up yeah one of the highest
teams in the NBA it was up it was up you
had Al Harrington Stephen
well he's got a week
yeah yeah but he he based that off his
grandma and then Matt Barnes Matt Barnes
pothead oh my goodness Steven Jackson
pothead
me I'm smoking
I'm a smoker I'm not a pothead just I
mean I wouldn't say that I'm a I'm a I
smoke right but I ain't no pot you know
I guess now maybe [__] how crazy was
like the Bay Area nightlife scene in
like not crazy not crazy because it
still wasn't crazy yeah it's not crazy
but it was up you know what I mean when
we was winning it was up because that
was like right after like the hyphy era
was like
in the middle it was almost
yeah we were still getting hyphy and
[__] uh you know to kick the snake we
was running we was running that up uh
who else was we Running Out Mr Fab house
Federation Federation that was all that
was older yeah we was uh obviously 40's
always 40. 40 was cool now let me ask
you 41 around when we was 40 was not
that's what I was gonna ask 40 wasn't
around front row 40 Front Row 40 when it
was the We Believe team no uh never we
have to talk about 40 next time I see
him I'll be like you know did he said
you wasn't there bro you know he wasn't
there he went no he he showed up a
couple times and [__] but you got to
think like in that time E-40 was touring
and traveling true yeah
ghetto report the [__] with Fab and all
that so for us it was like [__] if E40
would have came to the game it would
have like we match E40 right you feel
what I'm saying like our energy match
E40 like we we the ones who started
telling the Warriors yeah why are we
playing Bay Area Music when we at home
you know what I mean I remember uh I'm
only in town for the night oh yeah the
uh the Mr fabston yeah yeah yeah
everybody just started dancing and [__]
[__] the labs we just started grooving
in the line it was cool man we gotta we
had a great fun team and it matched the
personality of the city of the city yeah
of the whole entire Bay you know what I
mean because it wasn't just like oh we
were snugging out smoking weed and [__]
like that like no we was doing a lot bro
I was like I just started getting into
Tech you know uh Matt and stack they
were always in the city doing you know
dope charity work Monte was doing you
know yeah
was a young young boy he was a young dog
yeah he was a young dog black Rich had
been there for five six seven years
doing everything Jay Rich is a beast he
gave the sons a couple of great years
man yeah yeah Jay Rich Man when we when
I when I got there
I was like man I remember sitting on the
bus and we was all like man can we make
a playoff run yada yada we was like in
the middle I run I said man
we gotta do this [__] for Jay Rich this
man has been in this organization for
seven years five years and had eight
coaches in five years crazy and RJ Rich
wanted to do was get to the playoffs he
was the best teammate he wanted to hoop
and get to the playoffs and he kept
playing hurt you know what I mean [__]
like that and I remember because
I was a little older in my career
was like this because of injuries like I
didn't give a [__] I just wanted to play
because yeah it's harder to not play I
had a lot of injuries in your career and
it was harder to not play because all
the [__] that was going on that you can
get involved in when you just hurt not
playing and people got access
like you're on the road hey I'm busy I
ain't got no time so I think you know
even with Jay Rich he kept coming back
hurt and I was like man take your time
come back bro cause like
you what we need you know what I mean
and like I was just happy that we make
the playoffs because like if you feel
our energy like it was all like yo we
got to get to the playoffs for Jay Rich
we Jay Rich you got to get in the
playoffs like you in the playoffs you
gonna go crazy and he did he did what's
up y'all we got to stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our good
friends at my bookie that's right it is
NBA Finals you gotta Hammer the Nuggets
I don't know they might sweep the heat I
would look at the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus all right look I don't
care where you're at you can go to
mybookie.ag Let's gamble on some sports
they got the casino you can do live
Blackjack you can do live roulette craps
you could do all kinds of slots and of
course bet on the NBA Finals bet on the
NHL uh Stanley Cup finals crazy shots of
the Vegas golden knights that's what I'm
rooting for and of course baseball
season man all right so look right now
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
uh and sign up when you do use uh that
promo code they're going to give you a
first deposit bonus straight to your
account free money all right mybookie.ag
go do that also got to give a shout out
to our family at Blue chew that's right
ladies and gentlemen it's getting hot
outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to uhboochu.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now
there's Bluetooth work yes it does
you're gonna get a free month supply to
be able to see for yourself blue
shoe.com promo code bootleg uh now if
you don't know what it is it is the same
active ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
but in a chewable form and you do not
have to go to a doctor's appointment all
right you do everything online you don't
have to go sit at a doctor's office and
talk to some old man in a lab coat about
your dick issues not necessary anymore
in 2023 all right so go to Bluetooth
sign up with that promo code bootleg get
a month supply for free let's get back
to the interviews have you ever gotten
bipped in the bay
what's that where they crack your window
and take a [__] no uh-uh and you know
that's the thing in the in the bay
they'd be bipping it's called bip City
oh is it I didn't know that so like now
if you go to the Bay anything I got no
car I'm taking like lifts well if you
have a rental they say like anybody will
tell you
you roll your windows down and you pop
your trunk open when you park so that
way when you go into your restaurant or
you're going to a hotel or whatever yeah
they know still Dippers will drive by
and they've already been it's been hit
no no no they won't even bother it
because they'll know ain't nothing in
there
the thing is is they'll crack your
window even if they don't see anything
the window's getting cracked no matter
just because it's an inconvenience they
burnt out for that now everybody in the
bag all the windows down you gotta Pop
the trunk let's see take everything in
that's it yeah it's wild yeah they crazy
in the bed super crazy [__]
yo talk to me about the UCLA days man
because uh one of my best friends uh is
a UCLA Bruin and he was in college in a
fraternity when you were playing and he
was just like
so excited when I told him that you were
going to be on the show uh what was like
the energy being because an LA kid at
UCLA obviously UCLA was crazy yo you
guys were were really good yeah we we
had once again some problems my freshman
year Shake cotton they didn't let in he
was supposed to come with us uh and then
Jelani and Chris they got caught up you
know for smoking during uh like the
first year or whatnot
um and so we kind of played like
everybody played out of position my
freshman year we started two point
guards Toby Paley played like three
Chris Johnson played the 4jr Henderson
played the five and so
um it was crazy because we had all the
talent if our if our team would have
potentially came together you know what
I mean and we could have sustain it we
had all the talent to go out and win it
so UCLA it's all about winning national
championships for sure so for me it was
just like man like I want to win a
National Championship but I also want to
like like this [__] on fire you know
what I mean like let's send it up you
know and so you know
crosses dunks all that like we were
there to like no matter what we gonna We
gonna create some entertainment you know
what I mean growing up watching UCLA
basketball it was always like they were
always good always highlights so I was
like man I gotta go there and like I
gotta make sure I get my highlights
right you know what I mean like they
remember me yeah it was more so like
they have to remember me like I can't
just be you know a traditional point
guard that got good stats and make all
conference now I gotta do some [__]
where these people are gonna remember me
you know what I mean do you feel like
USC is slowly taking over La absolutely
no I gotta ask you know they got
James
they're definitely taking over I mean
they've kind of had football I ain't
even got football we beat them
listen the the link Lincoln Riley's a
hell of a coach hey man you know it's a
famous quote
it's just SC
it's just SC don't worry about it it's
so crazy too because those two colleges
like if for people who don't know like
if you were to just drive around USC
it's in South Central right yeah and
then if you go to the other side of town
it's It's UCLA it's like night and day
The Vibes of the campuses yeah just the
students like the student flavor and
energy is different
you know like uh SC got like more of a
downtown like they more like downtown so
they got like a a New York kind of vibe
right you know what I mean or like a I
don't know a downtown Vibe on the West
Side people chilling super laid out you
know we're going to the beach you know
people from SC they not driving all the
way to the you know what I mean they're
not driving all the way to the beach
they're going to go trying to find a
rooftop pool right
um talk to me about because I always do
say that hip-hop and basketball have
always been so heavily aligned they're
parallel to each other uh there's been
uh numerous artists outside of yourself
that have had ventures in hip-hop I mean
I remember growing up in Phoenix Amari
Stoudemire had a label yeah everybody
Carmelo had a label
um yeah I'm forgetting somebody yeah
do you remember the
you are his best kept secrets yes yes of
course Jason Kidd had a song Jason Kidd
uh Brian Shaw had a song Cedric ceballos
said had a video out great DJ um
he can get down uh who else was on that
album uh I had it I bought it from the
warehouse yeah I feel like I got it I
remember just being like what these guys
are rap hey dude they was getting off
too it was good uh Dana barrels he had a
song and a video it was sick but but
that's what I'm that's what I'm doing
now that's what I was gonna say you're
obviously involved in in um you've
always had your hand in Hip Hop yeah I
feel like even when you're in the league
you'd pop up in a game video or you
would be you know around a lot of these
guys since obviously ending your career
what has been because you've been
involved in so much on the entertainment
side kind of give me a rundown on what's
going on on the music side with you
right yeah so uh I created this
character barred oatmeal Bart oatmeal is
the legend the legend is barred oatmeal
uh his tag get a bow you know what I
mean uh you ain't got to get one you
know you can bring one if you have one
uh and so I just start thinking about
like damn my career over
I'm DJing I want to get better as a DJ
start producing start sampling producing
doing all that [__] and then nobody
would rap to my Beats so I was like all
right well I'll start riding and rapping
spinning my own beats can't be worse
than Chris Webber's nah bro I gotta hate
I'm just saying because Chris Webber had
a beat on another he had like two beats
on it was [__] Terror it was the
worst songs
and I love Chris Webber but I was like
yo there's whatever we got beats that's
that NBA sauce when nah says yes to that
beat it's because you're a question
Chris Webber
it was a dumb sample he had a dope
sample here oh no man
so I'd have to see where he took the
sample from the from The Wiz on that uh
uh on that song with the nas song I
don't know the one knot song on the on
Hip Hop is Dead uh was not which wasn't
for me
[Laughter]
I'm producing yeah ain't nobody rapping
to my [__] all the rappers around here
they like oh yeah that's cool you know
I'm like all right send me send me the
record back you know it was curtains
crickets really yeah but I also feel
like it was early too
and so uh I was like man I'm just gonna
keep grinding I don't play basketball no
more so I go to the gym go to the studio
and I start making a studio basketball
because then I got a chance to write so
write a script
one day I write a script one day I write
a short story one day I write you know
just start making music and start
writing it so I started making music
start writing and I wanted to create
this character Bart oatmeal I could
speak and say whatever the hell he
wanted to um you know what I mean
because Barton Baron completely
different Bart says something it doesn't
yeah and Bart is yeah Bart Baron Davis
created Bart oatmeal Bardo Mill is
slowly not [__] with Baron Davis okay
if that makes sense would you say the
uphill battle for you is like
because we know you as Baron Davis yeah
for sure so it's hard because we I don't
think we've really seen Damien Lillard's
done a decent job recently of like yeah
for sure you can really you know he can
get down he's dumb um but is that the
uphill battle for you you would think
it's it's like a benefit but it's also
kind of not but because people see you
as a as a legendary NBA player NBA
player yeah
um
I mean it's whatever you know what I
mean it is what it is it's fun for me
you're you're doing it because you want
to yeah I'm doing it yeah I'm like you
know it's also like mental therapy you
know what I mean
I went to the art like it's like going
into the Arts
allow me to be able to like kill a lot
of that anxiety you feel what I'm saying
or be able to sit and watch a game and
not have anxiety about if I would or
should have did it you know yeah none of
that bro it's just now I get to be
around another community and build a
community of like dope artists I still
[__] with my NBA dudes you know what I
mean now they rapping so it gives me
reason again to be involved because I
can produce yeah curate and then bring
the NBA dudes and the rappers together
for Ballers yes sir yes you are hell
yeah okay so I know a couple of guys
that rap that you might not do you know
Jaren Jackson Jr wraps absolutely yeah
yeah so yeah he's recorded here yeah
he's hard obviously Trip J what up boy
he comes that's my dog game damn it's
called miles Bridges miles Bridges who
is actually dope dope super dope bones
Highland dope bones Highland raps uh I
mean Katie has a song from like 12 years
ago yeah you got to bring the whole
everybody together man yeah all the
dudes is like Ola Depot he's saying oh
yeah he could sing like uh Serge Ibaka
he got like kind of like uh like an
afrobeat Vibe yeah no uh for people yeah
Victor all the Depots though yeah Victor
Oladipo can sing for real for real uh
who else is a couple other people uh
Kawhi rap Kawaii DeMar DeRozan oh I put
it uh he put a um he put a compilation
out but Kawaii rap see I I I I yeah I
got I got I was in the studio hard
because I have hard I have apps I have
no idea to me I would I would only
assume he has zero flow nah he's hard
bro he's just like mundane
does he rap like he talks in his press
conferences no okay I gotta hear this
[__] no it's it's crazy because you know
he we all chilling in the studio and he
playing and [__] I'm like man who is
that this [__] going he's like
yo that's my God that's you he's like
hell yeah wow like he dope
um DeMar DeRozan is dope I I don't doubt
that hey they're friends with a lot of
dope rappers yeah Demar sound like God
damn
2000 like he should have been out with
in the game man hell yeah Demar Hart
DeMarco
um who else
uh Terry Rozier is hard Scary Terry
Scary Terry is hard
um yeah it's a bunch of those I just
been like dming those uh Darren Waller I
think John Moran wants to be a rapper I
mean [__] so you should put him on
something for sure I'm sure he can have
some free time I'm sure he can I'm sure
he can what would be everybody act like
he going to jail or something no you're
gonna have free time he gonna be uh it's
like bro he's not going to jail he
didn't commit a crime there's no crime
committed everybody in the world's like
damn John Moran going to jail jump
around like about to do life it's like
no he's not bro
don't commit a crime I know I think this
is I think the whole thing is very
overblown for the record I just think
that you know once again we go back to
social media you go back like think
about this right
every day you wake up your basketball
content you get in from who
social media Stephen A oh yeah Stephen A
or skip or skip yeah Shannon sharp JJ
Redick JJ Reddit Richard Jefferson
like man
who's credible
I mean JJ Redick and Richard man if you
don't knock it off
how can JJ I mean and I love JJ right
but I'm here but it's a great career man
listen bro he had a long career so did
so did Richard Jefferson so
they had a great career but the what
made JJ Reddick
like what made me kind of sour on JJ
Redick is how he disrespected Jerry was
hmm you feel what I'm saying
that was it I'm gonna lead out at that
you know what I mean yeah because JJ
Redick should never speak on Jerry West
they're different you can't even sit at
the same table bro if it's a big ass
basketball banquet you are not you know
what I mean you're not at the same table
as Jerry West well Jerry West's not even
talking to you bro to be fair though it
ain't no to be fair I think Jerry West
he said Jerry West played with what
plumbers
right now go back to JJ ready clip and
he said man I shoot 300 jumpers a day
you know what I mean I do my workouts is
harder bro and you couldn't fix a car
and go play basketball
JJ Redick did all this just to be in the
NBA
you couldn't have been a mechanic and
did that but like so you couldn't have
played when they was mechanics right I
think so I don't want to hear that you
know what I mean I can't I can't listen
to that because you put all this work in
to be average
he he was a specialist he was average
right right he was not an All-Star he
was a he was an average Bridge great
role player he was average he was a good
role player he was average okay we
Jerry West
yeah
like the only thing I don't like is like
a lot of times people would just be
saying [__] for like clickbait or cloud
or probably what they personally feel
but when you look at you know I'm a
historian when you look at the game it's
like you can't disrespect it's an errors
thing got him damn near 30-something
Bird shoot better than you that's right
I look at the basketball convo kind of
like the hip-hop convo right because you
can't say something you can't say oh
[__] you can't disrespect Run DMC
because
when they when they started making hip
hop it was a different art form whatever
disrespect everyone but I'm saying like
when we talk about the all-time great
list right for sure guys like Run DMC
even like rock him somehow gets like
Spike slept on yeah it does because it's
different hip-hop dudes was talking [__]
about Tupac
you feel what I'm saying they was
talking [__] it's talking about Tupac
couldn't rap that's you know what I mean
and it was like okay who's saying this
right yeah no that's fair what are you
rapping you know that was my whole thing
like so like
you waking up getting your media from
like
five people true big perk shout out to
perk shout out to Parker's hilarious
yeah
he sounds like bun being Pimp C when he
says when he says
he's from Port Arthur Texas sounds like
UGK bro
big Park be up there rapping tune-ups
did they ever try to like hit you to try
to do something similar yeah I feel like
uh like I feel like
yeah I just never auditioned I did the
TNT thing that was cool but it was uh it
was just what about a podcast would you
do a podcast yeah I feel like I should
do it you should man there's lots of
money out there and there's some shitty
shitty basketball players doing podcasts
uh no getting money uh no yeah there's
some real role players out here yeah I
mean it's some real people that
shouldn't be talking out here
I shouldn't be talking about certain
[__] you know what I mean you mentioned
something earlier that like doing music
writing being a creative now helps kind
of you keep your mind off of maybe some
of the what ifs of your NBA career you
were somebody whose career was filled
with a lot of what ifs because you had a
lot of injuries yeah
give me like how hard because I don't
think we hear the side of like somebody
like you who's an All-Star who you know
I mean at your Peak when you're healthy
can play with anybody in the league
when you have one of those careers where
there's a lot of injuries
much does that weigh on you mentally
when you start like thinking too much
about like damn if I'd have been healthy
or what if or yeah like is that a hard
thing to kind of it's like it turns with
a deterioration of the mind right when
you think about if I Woulda Shoulda
Coulda
and you can't do nothing else about it
you know what I mean it's like I can't
turn it around you know uh after I
retire and be like all right I'm gonna
go ahead and do all this [__] right you
know what I mean it was just
you have to accept
life and what you thought your NBA
career was going to be I suppose what it
actually is and then you gotta learn to
appreciate like
there were better players in you that
has shorter NBA careers you know what I
mean there are sorrier players that have
had illustrious careers you know what I
mean 100 you made it fool yeah like who
is cut Like You Who Came From what you
came from you know what I mean and then
you should respect everybody who's
played in this league from here to here
so everybody gets respect and
appreciation and I think for me it was
like all right now I can leave that [__]
right there
I'm done I want to leave it there yeah
and like I can't talk about like I can
talk about it all day if I would or
should I can talk about it but if I
start living in that in that energy
yeah I'm be thinking about that all the
time so me I can never really be present
right and I can never really be
half Pride or the confidence you know
what I mean that I need to be present
because I'm always thinking about
some [__] went wrong I [__] up I
should have did this I should have did
that or what if I would have got hurt or
if I wouldn't have got hurt yeah but
like so many okay yeah if I wouldn't
have got hurt like it had been cracking
but I got hurt yeah and a part of like
me being hurt was like I always played
hurt so it was never that was just your
career yeah my whole career I was never
healthy right you know what I mean it
was like not one year maybe one year or
two that I kind of came into the season
like I feel good yeah you know what I
mean like other than that it was always
like I came in college with a I can't
just came off ACS my fresh my first year
in the league I had torn cartilage in my
knee I never got surgery second year in
the league still had that torn cartilage
had a little minor surgery in the
off-season played that came back played
the second year third year that's when
my back started you know what I mean
like crazy so it was just always were
dealing with it but it was like I
couldn't it's like you'd be hurt
but then it's like God damn I just start
like you can't be out there you start
feeling bad you want to work harder you
can't work as hard as you want to get
you can overthink yourself into a place
yeah yeah
hell yeah it's not it's not easy yeah
you know what I mean it's not easy like
you know waking up every day and like
you know thinking about
can I do this again you know what I mean
like
do they love me you know what I mean
it's like well you're like you're not
playing you know what the one thing
about you Baron was I feel like anybody
who was like a true basketball fan like
really appreciated when you were playing
because you were like you I feel like
you were kind of like
like like hoop heads like kind of like
[__] guy you know there's like a few
guys like you like I remember I used to
love watching stuff on Mulberry
yo that last Knicks team you played on
was were you on the team when the Lynn
sanity [__] happened absolutely
what was that like to be because [__] it
was the craziest [__] ever dude got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the world
ladies and gentlemen uh go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg calf or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a toader a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it and then you press on the thingy
you know what I'm saying and then you
got flavor I'm going to show you what it
looks like when it's stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
all right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms maybe you already know what
it is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout half
off at checkout fifty percent off if you
go to kingpom.com and use that promo
code the promo code is down below go run
it up try some of these flavors too man
the peach pineapple the Strawberry
Shortcake they just got so much going on
there's also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview
because it was kind of like my locker
was next to Jeremy Lin's oh so it was
cracking after those games not it was no
it wasn't cracking it was like my locker
is here Jeremy Jeremy Lynn Locker is
here and there's a 150 media and a lot
that's what I mean
not cracking I you have to leave you
have to hey man hold on let me get my
[__] let me let me go change in the in
the regular bathroom in the bathroom
stall hey dude Jeremy Lynn had the whole
team changing in the [__] shower
wherever we could you couldn't be in
that locker room they had to move him
from the locker room and every interview
he had was a press conference
crazy it was like 150 people every time
he had to get interviewed he couldn't do
it in the locker room because it'd be
too many people in the locker locker
room you couldn't change you couldn't
stretch you couldn't do [__] so they
have to like take him to another school
was Dan Tony coaching that team Dan Tony
was yeah it's crazy because I think like
me and Dan Tony used to call Jeremy Lin
Angels in the Outfield
watch out cause I told them because I
Jeremy Lin was there to like help me get
back to planning so I needed another
week and so that's how he wind up
staying that week playing against bro uh
the Brooklyn Nets and then going on his
run
that's how you got his other 10 day
because I wasn't ready my back was still
[__] up and I was like if you would
have been healthy we might not ever she
would have never seen Jeremy Lynn great
there was like this thing because uh
mellow was injured at the time right
yeah he went on that run yeah because I
told mellow Mello was carrying the team
yeah Mello was carrying the team and he
was like you know we were struggling
dude we was like losing by six losing by
four and it was all due to we didn't
have a point guard that went downhill
because Mike Bibby was on the team right
on the team but Mike Bibby was [__] my
Bibby was towards at the end of his
career for sure Tony Douglas was a point
guard but not really a point guard Iman
Shumpert was a rookie who was a shooting
Garden out of point guard rookie jump on
that team yeah so like with J.R Smith on
that two second time he played with JR
yeah J.R Smith you played with him as a
rookie yeah he was my rookie yeah but
like his rookie year was uh the I feel
like that was the year I got traded to
Golden State yep yeah so I think it was
yep so you know played with him for like
a half a year yeah but he's you know
Swiss used to live with me oh yeah like
he lived with his parents in New Orleans
but like you know when he wanted to go
out and hang out
so so it's just like my little bro for
life I was gonna say with the Mellow
Jeremy Lin thing I remember the national
narrative was like uh you know house
mellow gonna play with Jeremy Lin when
he comes back from being healthy was
there like any sort of like ever any
tension in the locker room between that
with that whole situation uh it was some
weird [__] going on because
obviously like we riding a wave Super
Wave and and the linsanity wave is and
mellow out remember he was injured when
he when he went on that run yeah yeah he
gonna run we went like five six in a row
mellow comeback
but lamello come back
Jeremy Lin is the biggest star in the
world [__] it [__] New York in the world
[__] New York the world bro for sure
the world he's the he has literally went
from like nobody to the face of the NBA
hey you gotta remember also I feel like
we are just transitioning out of the
whole lockout remember the lockout
squeeze so we're about a year and a half
or maybe two and a half years in so it's
like the league is still needing a thing
to happen man when that thing happened
it was like Melo came back and Jeremy
Lin was so big he was bigger than mellow
media wise yeah and so it did create a
little like
this [__] is not real like we can't we
can't live in this is sustainable or not
yeah bro we can't live in this but like
we should be living in it but I think
like it started to create
um
like tension in the in our in the way we
play
um
because I feel like because it's still
mellow teams mellow is still the dog you
know what I mean mellow is still our
goal was Amari on the team yet Amari was
on the team right Omari was injured and
coming back but remember it was omari's
team first yeah Mari had that Amari
first year when he was on it had a
rocket when he had that first year with
the Knicks he had it rocking
he had it rocking another injury another
I mean yeah think about that like like
now imagine Amar'e Stoudemire or what if
why why would I sit here and be
questioning myself crazy when you got
people like you know Amar'e Stoudemire
Brandon Roy yeah Brandon Roy Penny
Hardaway Grant Hill Grant Hill would
have might be might probably be the top
10 player ever Sean Livingston John
Livingston like bro we ain't even get to
see the real Sean living I mean we saw
it we saw him he had a great career saw
him have an incredible career but you
didn't see what could have been you know
what I mean but you can't live on that
[__] was Mike D'Antoni
um because I'm a Suns fan so obviously I
have a place in my heart for Him how was
he like to to play with was it was he
doing the seven seconds or less [__]
with you guys uh Mike nantoni was as a
coach was cool yeah no defense did you
not give a [__] about defense this is
what you're talking about no defense
okay okay he wasn't talking about he
wasn't talking about it yeah he ain't
talking about no defense just seven
seconds or less it's your offense yeah
no it wasn't so much seven of seconds it
was just more so like he needed
his point guard to go north south yep
and as talented as you were being able
to go north south
his point guard was the most integral
part of the of the offense because any
time the point guard goes downhill the
whole Lane goes the whole defense yeah
because you got Shooters you got
Shooters surrounding yeah and then if
the big man is setting a pick you really
playing two on two basketball if they
stay at home so like that's why Steve
Nash was so good you know Chris Duhan
had 31 assists
on the Knicks Duhan was a [__] I
remember having his fantasy basketball
one year and his system in in dantoni's
system
if you're a point guard and you go north
that's why Jeremy Lin was so successful
because at the time he could penetrate
that pain man he just put his head down
drive right and go and he he's not bad
he can make plays at The Rim he can
finish he's a bigger guard you know what
I mean but if you go downhill even if
you get in trouble somebody's open facts
and so like that's kind of like
the dantoni system that's why I went to
the Knicks you know at the end of the
day because I was like damn if I can get
right yeah right I can't I can Steve
Nash this [__] you know what I mean yeah
hell yeah but it's just like I [__] my
[__] up I came in in the next not
thinking I'll be able to walk again was
Isaiah Thomas the GM at the time no uh
it was uh Glenn gronwald okay shout out
to Isaiah Thomas yeah very scared that
he's gonna take over the sun's Jam
position we'll see oh that could be dope
I don't know would it be we'll see he's
real tight with Matt ishpit so yeah
that'll be dope we'll see I'm just
liking I'm like I think James Jones is
there now yeah James is great yeah James
Jones is cool uh okay give me a quick
your favorite teammate you've ever
played with and the best teammate
skill-wise you've ever played with your
favorite and the best there's two
separate things yeah they could be the
same person yeah I would have to say
probably like
damn dude I got so many favorites I hate
doing that [__] just give me give me the
first one that comes to mind without
well you know or give me a couple
Montiel is Eldon Campbell Eldon Campbell
the OG big homie wow Alden camel is the
original and I need people to know this
he is the original big homie there's
nobody in the league that was calling
they sent her big homie outside of us
Eldon Campbell took the whole big home
was she on the Hornet yeah me him
Derrick Coleman uh Coleman was on the
wall hell yeah dude we have some crazy
super OG's hey dude we had Derek coming
used to bomb on me wow hey man
the nicest scariest
you know what I mean Big Brother you
could ever have Coleman he's a very
underrated power forward he was super
underrated yeah yeah so okay PJ Brown
was on that Squad Eldon Campbell is the
first big homie so you know eat my big
homie that's so funny yeah okay what
about the best the best teammate I've
probably ever played with
but that's tough yeah
this one uh I mean I play with Melo with
the Knicks so I saw I wasn't like where
I was but he was doing some crazy [__]
Jamal Mashburn you gotta put him up
there cold you gotta put him up there
what about on the Clippers what about
during the Clippers run who was there's
nobody no Blake I came but he was young
but nobody yeah yeah not not like me
when Blake got drafted he didn't play
the first year yeah he got hurt the
first year and then he came back his
rookie year was really his second year
his second year but he got hurt his
rookie year I feel like I think he did
too yeah yeah I feel like he got hurt
the rookie year too I was on your
Clippers team because I remember Greg
DeAndre were my rookies Eric Bledsoe is
my rookie Eric Gordon was my rookie
Jesus that's a lot those are some guys
yeah those are my rookies
um who else was on the team I can't
remember Craig Smith my Rhino from here
uh Eric Gordon yeah those are my rookies
uh Ryan Gomes was on that team I believe
yeah Eric Gordon yeah we you know we had
we had it cracking like when we when we
had the black [__] and DeAndre died so
what's your rookie too yeah
the Dark Ages is when the only Jersey I
could go by at our team shop was Eric
was Eric I have Eric Bledsoe Jersey in
my closet on the other point guard from
uh Kentucky what was his name he was
really nice uh Utah Tyler Tyler uh uh
Ennis
the short kid I like that kid um all
right last question
um hardest player to defend that you had
to play against
hardest player to defend yeah oh man
okay let me tell you this
unfair
I am a point guard six three maybe 215
218.
at the guard
Michael Jordan
on the word on the Wizards on the
wizards but which was still up the
50-point game
wait you're regarding Jordan when he
didn't score them all he scored like 8
10 on me
talking
us up I'm going to tell you this is
where I think there's a Michael Jordan
like Matrix you can fall into
because you watching them and he's
scoring and making this [__] look easy
and he's entertaining and you as the
offense and the defense you just fall
asleep like admiring
hey bro Jordan Hayes where you're just
like it's called the timeout Lee nalen
was guarding him in the beginning Paul
Silas called the timeout man what the
[__] y'all doing and everybody's sitting
there like
you know like damn do this Jordan you
got 16 points like man y'all just
watching this dude like we were
literally like you were fans watching
him like like damn dude like go ahead
like like you're not gonna help do you
OG do you
Bros ill it was Ill because
you know then it was like all right [__]
it I got him and he hit me with the fade
and it's like damn I ain't getting no
hell I'm looking around everybody
looking at me like God that was some
good defense
well I think people try to like that's a
good defense Jordan wasn't cold on the
Wizards he was cold I watched Jordan he
gave us a 50p show went to the all-star
game
we had beat them in Charlotte I think I
had 30 Mash had 20 something you know
what I mean and so the whole you know
Jordan got to get his bounce back [__]
like that 50 points that's what this
[__] yeah man he came out of here like
16 in the first quarter I seen I was
watching it I was there this is all this
like I'm like damn he just got 16 okay
[__] damn you got 24 at halftime yeah we
got 40 in the third quarter and you're
just admiring it
no by the time halftime come around you
like hey man we can't let this
[__] get fixed this guy he's a
lot older than us guys like like bro
he's doing everything it's it's over
you're doing everything to stop him now
it's over he him Rip Hamilton jahidi
white it's like the most random like
assortment of players on the Wizards man
it was like it's like he coming out of
the game it's like almost like you know
people just getting they flow getting
shots and [__] actually not like man
this [__] got 24 like and you
playing hard you know what I mean but
it's still like the intensity of the
game ain't picked up yet wow and by the
time you your intensity level pick up
like he laughing at you at that point
what about the most underrated guy that
you played against because there's a lot
of players who don't get Brandon Roy
Nick Van axel Jason Terry Terry's a
beast uh uh Damon Stoudemire
um
Michael red Michael Redd when he was on
the Bucks uh Darren Williams yes shout
out to D will uh
Jared Jack
assistant coach for the Suns well I
don't know if he is anymore because you
know I just think that dude was highly
underrated I think he's going to Detroit
uh I think
um Tony Parker yeah I mean Hall of Famer
but like still bro you don't talk we
don't talk enough we talk more about
Chris Paul than we do Tony Parker and
Parker got the Rings to me Parker top
five point guard all time really fight
it wow I mean if you look at it you know
where he sit you got him above CP all
time have to yeah four titles um
that's fair I mean you know what I mean
like if you putting it like you know you
got Stockton you got magic you got
Isaiah yeah you got
Steph
you got to put stuff in there yeah Steph
is yeah yeah you got Steph I think steps
you got Tony Parker
I put CP in the in that five spot I
think I just think Parker was blessed to
play in that spur system
I think if you put Chris Paul in this
one I know but if you know you can't you
can't say that they wouldn't have won
um last thing if you put Chris Paul I'm
a Spurs they win the one you don't think
so
hmm nope because Chris Paul played a
different style like people
people don't appreciate Tony Parker I
agree
that dude was called listen as a Sons
fan who had yeah
you hate him you hate him we had our
hearts ripped out by the [__] Spurs
but I would say he's probably the most
underrated person that people don't talk
about yeah I even think somehow Tim
Duncan is like don't give Tim Duncan
yeah no for sure you should just hate
watched him yeah like you people no
emotion when he scored I'm like dude can
you can you get it together you just
nonchalantly cooking us sending us home
every [__] playoffs uh anyway well
look uh anything going on uh can you
kind of give us a quick idea on what's
going on on the music side yeah Bart
oatmeal you know down low I am not I am
at Bart oatmeal at Bart dot oatmeal
um you know I've been working with some
dope uh producers Mike and keys shout
out to them uh shout out big shout out
to Mike and keys the AP in the album uh
I got my young producers in the Sean and
AI with me uh got some stuff from
no ID shout out to no idea uh he the
legend you know what I mean and uh I got
a song with G Perico Dom Kennedy J Stone
just keeping it you know uh glasses
Demar just lots of glasses Man glasses
is imagining that's my dog he was around
Black Wall Street days early Black Wall
Street days so uh I gotta join with Mr
Fab Big Rich from the bay Big Rich is
he's managing artists yeah he is yeah I
brought Big Rich out of retirement he's
like man you gonna bring me out of
retirement so I just uh [__] like that
man I got a cool little album that's out
right now uh my brother the big Scott
and slim cutters La to LA and then I got
my little uh Bartow Mill get a ball one
that's on iTunes and then I'm gonna
shout out to Jay worthy Rock Marciano
I'm on that project I got two joints on
that project worthy man doing say worthy
[__] dog yeah hell yeah he was like top
three on the Hip Hop so much amazing
yeah you're getting this [__] off we got
a tape coming together oh [__] we got a
tape coming together uh who else I got
it uh working on a tape with somebody
else we just said it was gonna do a tape
together I know me and G Perico got a
tape coming out I gotta be crazy yeah we
got we got some you know faux songs [__]
like that but uh I'm looking to drop
mine
probably end of June did game ever try
to like
sign you to Black Wall Street back in
the day no because everybody was on
Black Wall Street no I was kind of like
the uh executive you know I was kind of
like the executive juice was on there
everybody shout out to Jules uh uh uh
uh what was his name
life was there Black Wall Street was a
rest in peaceful bent yeah yeah he was
an illness yeah man [__] the black
Eastwood was on blood yeah he was also
on death row yeah Eastwood was on death
row and Black Wall Street that's so wild
man I appreciate your time man thank you
bro I definitely I I need to come see
your spot
um you gotta come through game three we
cracking we got the watch party Denver
Miami so we got a Jimmy Butler gifting
Suite uh for game three and four come
get some Jimmy Butler swag really why
not a jokish gifting Suite uh cause you
know we rocking with Jimmy Butler that's
the brand that's paying I'm a huge I'm a
huge when they pay when they pay for the
studio and you know Nike or somebody pay
for the studio we have a joke is sweet
I hate watch jokic you're crazy
is over no I hate watching it's over no
no like he's so good I know he's so good
that like I like yo you're a Phoenix
Suns I'm a basketball fan so I I love to
watch him yeah but it's like it's almost
like I'm it's like a hate watch you like
hating on it yeah no I I can't hate on
jokic I just can't do it it's like you
hate the fact that he's so good and he's
shaped like me and he's just like
so gifted I'm just like this giant
round mound of carcassidy is just out
here cooking everybody no for sure
nothing nobody he's got scraped up he's
bleeding out of both arms yeah he like
bruising easily and [__] what the [__]
hey dude he I'm so glad
that they are on the national stage me
too because remember he is the back to
back MVP MVP of the league
could easily be three times three times
MVP
and I'm so glad he's on this stage now
everybody so now everybody can shut up
everyone's talking [__] [__] on Twitter
I'm like you guys don't even know you've
never you've never watched basketball
yeah you just see it stop you see tick
tocks and reels and [__] yeah you see
stats and think like oh it ain't real no
this dude is like he is he is all time
with his [__] all time he is transcended
with his [__] you know what I mean so
it's just shout out to him man you know
shout out to Jimmy Butler too because
Jimmy Butler is another one that I say
is underrated you know what I mean it's
like
you don't know
you don't like it's not like oh there's
like a style yeah you know what I mean
like Jimmy Butler coming to win and get
out the mud
um I know I keep saying last thing but
promise you this is the last thing I'm a
Suns fan I just want to get your quick
take on the Sons Katie Booker and our
Frank Vogel coaching hire
what do you think man good higher bad
hire
I like Frank Vogel man I like them you
know uh um assistant kept Kevin Young on
as his assistant so we have the highest
paid assistant staff
so well it doesn't matter that don't
mean [__]
do you think listen do you think we have
a chance to get a ring with those two
with those two guys no no
all right well that's how we're gonna
end the interview I mean you know I love
the Suns I think that they uh have the
talent they're gonna trade ayton and
then Chris Paul's gonna go somewhere
else if they trade Chris Paul and Ayden
it depends on what they get
but I don't think that that team right
there that team is no no no Aidan is a i
i it's it's the thing is they don't
Phoenix don't play no defense
Frank when you think when you think
about yeah so if they start playing some
defense yeah they may be all right there
it is all right well all right Baron
Davis get a bow there it is appreciate
you brother appreciate it yes sir I got
it hey appreciate y'all watching another
interview brought to you by our good
Folks at hardean now listen y'all when
you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell him to take you to hard
Dean the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection to premium cannabis
you'll see period anywhere let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you won't get the best experience the
best customer service the best bud
tenders you walk into hard Dean and that
[__] just smells amazing they got their
own [__] scent literally you get into
my car I got a bottle of it my car
smells like Harding because it's just
the best [__] place um go follow him
online Harding underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're going to take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hardine all right you got
to go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank y'all man
I love these guys they're like family to
us and uh hey we're gonna drop another
interview soon if you're watching this
you're at the end of the interview
though much love